you
[Music]
in this quiet Suburban Town something
sinister is Sterling one mad scientist
toils away at his mechanical Abomination
where does he think he is
[Music]
he has one last bug to squash mom coming
home mom and dad had an argument last
night don't say the n-word around
two-year-olds oh honey is family
come on
come to the Attic Kids I have a surprise
typing with his gloves on again Dad
[Music]
it's the machine had blown up the kids
there'd be pieces of them everywhere
they're in the backyard he'll stop at
nothing to finish the job
sometimes
tiny things
come and cuddly packages
hang on this
you guys come on great idea Russ did you
report some missing children cars are in
the backyard
[Music]
all right
Honey I Shrunk the Kids
[Laughter]